das Menschen durch kurbelt Impfstoffe zu
Schäden zu Schaden gekommen sind zum
Beispiel Herzschädigung erlitten haben
oder wie sie das ist inzwischen bekannt
es gibt viele Berichte dazu
bislang wissen wir aber nicht sicher wie
viele Menschen betroffen sind
Geschädigte wenden sich wie sie auch
verzweifelt an Ärzte damit sie Ihnen
helfen und ihr Leid lindern aber auch an
uns Anwältin und um Schadensersatz zu
erhalten neben dem bekannten
versorgungsansprüchen auch über die wird
immer wieder berichtet die man gegen das
Land eben geltend machen kann gibt es
auch die Möglichkeit Hersteller oder die
impfenden Personen in Anspruch zu nehmen
das Problem dabei ist allerdings dass
die Versorgungsansprüche gegen das Land
keinen vollen Schadensersatzanspruch
beinhalten dafür sind allerdings die
Anforderungen geringer denn es ist ja
immer die Frage ist das wirklich ein
Impfschaden kann ich die Kausalität
zwischen Impfung und dem dem Leid was
man ertragen was man ähm erlitten hat
kann ich das nachweisen und das sind die
Anforderungen geringer aber was heißt
kein voller Schadensersatz das bedeutet
kein Schmerzensgeld das bedeutet kein
Ausgleich für erwerbsschaden und am Ende
bedeutet das eine ziemlich dürftige
kleine Rente also liegt natürlich nah
Hersteller impfende Personen in Anspruch
zu nehmen aber die brauchen wir darum
fast nicht zu befürchten denn das
haftungsregime was sonst eigentlich
relativ gut ist es gibt nämlich eine
Gefährdungshaftung für das Produkt wurde
von der Regierung der Art beschränkt
dass kaum noch Fälle übrig bleiben
dürften die den hohen Anforderungen
gerecht werden ich bin der Meinung dass
die Haftungsbeschränkung
verfassungswidrig ist denn das ganze
wurde perverordnung einfach nur gemacht
ich fürchte aber dass nach den
Erfahrungen nach zweieinhalb Jahren
Corona Rechtsprechung dass ich mir nicht
sicher bin ob ein Gericht sich zu dieser
Feststellung durchdringen kann
was heißt das meine Einschätzung nach
können daher die allerwenigsten
Betroffenen ernsthaft auf vollen
Schadensersatz hoffen das heißt die
Klagen haben meines Erachtens sehr
geringe Erfolgsaussichten und es besteht
aber ein hohes Kostenrisiko weil da geht
zum richtig viel Geld ja wenn jemand
Managerin zum Beispiel war und jetzt
nicht mehr an Mitte 30 Anfang 40 nicht
mehr arbeiten kann da reden wir von
hunderten von tausenden was an Geld
einfach verloren geht ja und genau
deswegen sollte man wirklich gut drüber
nachdenken ob man dagegen vorgeht und
das gleiche sehe ich auch bei
außergerichtlichen vergleichszahlungen
auch die sind meines Erachtens nicht
oder allenfalls sehr wenig aber
tendenziell eher nicht zu erwarten die
Chancen sind sehr sehr gering da die
Anforderungen an den Nachweis so hoch
sind warum sollte sich der Hersteller
darauf einlassen ja das sieht dann auch
vieles nach sich und deswegen sehe ich
eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit und zwar
muss der Staat hier in die Verantwortung
gehen und zwar aus folgenden Gründen ich
habe hier vier Gründe warum ich Frage
dass der Staat hier eben für den
Schadensersatz komplett aufkommen muss
und die impfgeschädig nicht mehr alleine
lassen die Frage geben wir direkt mal
weiter an Herrn Bauschke ich fasse
einmal zusammen wenn man in der
Situation ist dass man davon ausgeht ein
Impfschaden zu haben ist es wahnsinnig
schwer wahnsinnig kostspielig überhaupt
jemanden zur Verantwortung zu ziehen und
vor allem kann das nicht mehr der
Hersteller tun diese Verantwortung wurde
abgegeben und soll jetzt die Politiker
sagen es gibt rechtlich und tatsächlich
wahnsinnig viele Fragen die offen sind
so dass man nur seriös sagen kann
man also das ist das muss richtig gut
überlegen soll ob man klagt und deswegen
ist der Staat in der Pflicht und zwar
aus wenn ich die die würde einmal kurz
abholen weil Stichwort Staat in der
Pflicht gerne noch mal gleich für ihren
Gründen aber statt in der Pflicht wird
der Stadt dieser Pflicht gerecht Muster
der Stadt in die Pflicht genommen werden
naja das ist eine sehr sehr große Frage
wir werden uns natürlich der
Verantwortung stellen müssen als Staat
und als als Gemeinschaft
wir werden zu dem Zeitpunkt und das ist
natürlich die Geschichte sowohl wieder
bei impfschädigungen oder bei Schäden
die durch die Impfungen entstanden sind
als auch die longkowitz-geschichte wo
wir ja auch Menschen haben die wirklich
eingeschränkt sind werden wir natürlich
irgendwo eine Struktur brauchen die das
abfedert ne also das Problematik glaube
ich in der Diskussion ist es Ihnen jetzt
im Grunde auch nichts geholfen wenn
Ihnen jetzt der Staat 25000 geben würde
sie wollen ja ihre Gesundheit ja das ist
so leid es mir tut halt nichts was man
einfach per Gesetz regeln kann sondern
das muss medizinisch begleitet werden
und deswegen brauchen wir da jetzt
natürlich eine Infrastruktur die genau
das machen wird also ich glaube auch
dass wir uns irgendwie über eine über
Fachkliniken unterhalten werden müssen
wir werden uns über gewisse Reha
unterhalten müssen und bei der Haftung
selber muss ich gestehen ja ich verstehe
das auch finanzielle Einbußen die können
individuellen Thema sein aber da bin ich
bei Ihnen was die Rechtsauffassung ist
ich glaube das ist jetzt noch nichts was
man jetzt angehen kann das wird aber die
Zeit zeigen
denn wenn wir jetzt das Beispiel was sie
auch gerade genannter haben wenn jemand
jetzt mit Ende 30 Anfang 40
arbeitsunfähig ist aufgrund eines
Impfschadens dann kann es finanziell
richtig eng werden und dann habe ich
schon die Frage woher kriege ich jetzt
haben wir sogar gesagt 25000 €. aber die
hätte ich dann schon gerne weil ich
irgendwie unter Wasser bleiben und diese
Frage ist natürlich irgendwann vor 30
Jahren oder 35-Jährigen die wegen
longovic nicht mehr arbeiten
wir können in der Diskussion ja bei dem
Thema Impfschäden wird es sicherlich
eine Frage auch sein wie man sozusagen
das rechtlich klärt wie gesagt das wird
auch eine Frage der Studien sein ich
kann Ihnen jetzt keine Studie aus dem
Hut zaubern weil das nicht mein Job ist
aber da wird die Frage sein sozusagen
ist der Schaden wirklich durch die
Impfung entstanden zu weit wie ich
zumindest das Medizinrecht aus
Erzählungen kenne glaube ich wird es von
der Herausforderung so riesig und
schwierig werden das ist gar kein Weg
gibt aber ich will ja den betroffen wenn
ich den Betroffene helfen will dann muss
ich eine Struktur aufbauen und an diese
Strukturen müssen wir jetzt dazu also
wir brauchen definitiv meine Forderung
eine davon wäre eben dass es staatliche
Beratungsstellen gibt die Menschen
erstmal umfassend aufklären das eine ist
gesundheitlich an wen können Sie sich
beenden werden zum Beispiel Thema dieses
mitmachen genau
also das wäre eine sehr gute Idee weil
die Struktur gibt schon es gibt die
verbraucherschutzzentral und ihnen dann
eben Hilfe zu gehen was kann ich richtig
machen wie kann ich einen Antrag auf
Entschädigung stellen was wie ist das
denn genau mit der Kausalität in ganz so
ist es nicht wenn man diese das muss man
noch mal deutlich machen der es gab eine
relativ gute Haftung im Asthma an
Arzneimittelgesetz durch die Verordnung
wurde die aber letztlich ja aufgehoben
denn da musste man nicht nachweisen dass
man da einen Impfschaden hat sondern es
war quasi eine Beweislast Umkehr das ist
ein guter Deal für die Politik es muss
so schnell gehen aber dann auch schnell
raus aus der Haftung sonst schrieb Jens
Spahn wir werden uns viel aneinander
verzeihen müssen ähm
ich verstehe natürlich diese Panik
Situationen damals herrschte aber wir
haben das Thema ja jetzt auch gerade
ganz akut beim Thema z.B Masken kaufen
und Equipment da sind viele Fehler
gemacht worden handwerklich ich würde
jetzt davor waren immer zurück zu zeigen
und zu sagen ob man das in der Situation
in der Verantwortung alles hätte richtig
machen können das glaube ich würde ich
mir selber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt
zutrauen aber es sind schon Sachen die
wir hinterleuchten müssen Fragen die
gestellt werden müssen und ich bin mir
hier und jetzt kommt zumindest mal
einfach mal nämlich der Historiker bei
mir durch ich glaube das ist zum
Beispiel auch ganz spannend wird wie wir
die Zeit auch wirklich aufarbeiten
sowohl juristisch als auch historisch
als auch gesellschaftlich einordnen gut
da gab es ja auch ihre Partei sitzen
jetzt in Berlin Abgeordnetenhaus aber
ihre Partei regiert ja mit hat ja im
Wahlkampf 2021 gesagt das müsste ein
Untersuchungsausschuss dann im Bundestag
geben zu dem Thema kaum ist man in der
Regierung soll es diese
Untersuchungsausschuss dann plötzlich
nicht mehr geben weil die SPD ja dann
mit dabei gewesen wäre als Mitglied der
Vorgängerregierung hätten alles so
gestimmt wie ich jetzt den
Untersuchungsausschuss gegeben dann
hätten wir keine Koalition gebraucht das
ist schon Bedenken das glaube ich ein
Punkt ganz wichtig
Untersuchungsausschuss ist etwas was
wirklich glaube ich entscheiden ist
einfach um Dinge aufzuarbeiten ich weiß
nicht ob die Verbraucherzentrale die
richtige Anlaufstelle ist wenn sie auch
schon sagen dass viele Ärzte selbst gar
nicht genau wissen mit ihrem Befund
umzugehen was sollen dann
Verbraucherzentralen tun ehrlicherweise
das glaube ich nicht und ich möchte
einmal nur mal sagen die Situation uns
vor Augen zu führen bei allem auch Frust
den Mann und Ärger und auch sorgen die
man zurecht haben kann auch wenn man
jetzt körperlich extrem angegriffen ist
und eingeschränkt ist durch die Impfung
in welcher Situation wir uns halt Ende
20 Anfang 21 befunden haben das ganze
Land stand still und es ist mit
Hochdruck an diesem Impfstoff gearbeitet
worden und wir wissen alle es gab ein
rollierendes Verfahren dass man
normalerweise nie macht nämlich das
plötzlich verschiedene
Studienphasen nebeneinander laufen wenn
man normal lässt man die eine Auslaufen
dann guckt man sich die Ergebnisse an
Sachen was verbessern wir jetzt um die
nächste Studie dann zu machen um
irgendwann das Produkt auf den Markt zu
bringen das ist ja nachher parallel
gelaufen einfach um das Tempo zu
beschleunigen aber genau deswegen ist
der Staat ja auch in der Pflicht also
das ist ein Punkt in den Verhandlungen
mit der der EU-Kommission beispielsweise
mit den Herstellern dass die Hersteller
gesagt haben wir gehen da aus der genau
wir gehen aus der Haftung dann raus und
dann hat sich absolut nachvollziehbar
genau und dann dadurch ist natürlich
oder möglicherweise auch noch mehr Tempo
äh generell in diese Bestellung
reingekommen und auch in die Lieferung
dann wenn man das schon mal zumindest
aus Hersteller sich ausgeschlossen hat
das hilft Ihnen in Ihrem persönlichen
schick mal überhaupt nicht verstehe ich
natürlich ich glaube das hilft ihnen in
ihrem persönlichen Schicksal anderen
auch nicht ich glaube aber auf der
anderen Seite und das darf man bei aller
persönlichen Betroffener glaube ich
nicht vergessen ich bin weiter der
Meinung hat ganz ganz vielen Millionen
trotzdem geholfen das hilft ihnen nicht
das verstehe ich auch und das ist auch
nicht kleiner reden genau da muss man
dann über die aber es hat halt umgekehrt
ich habe manchmal hier entsteht jetzt so
ein bisschen etwas im alles war schlecht
mit dieser Endung ich glaube umgekehrt
hat es halt ganz ganz vielen geholfen
und das dürfen wir nicht klein reden
sondern ich glaube mit Sicherheit auch
alle einig wir gehen jetzt ins dritte
Jahr mit Corona Vierteljahr und das
dritte Jahr
und wir hoffen alle dass wir aus Fehlern
die gemacht und gelernt haben das wäre
Dinge anders machen